cos'è questo un banjo banjo banjo e fede
mentre fedez esistono un clip è ok e da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo momento
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul più grande
e il più intelligente il più incredibile
è fantastico gioco della terra siamo
tornati su matrix ragazzi erano rimasti
che ho fatto il secondo capitolo che era
geniale capitolo 3 lega sono dal tratto
ce ne sono quattro il brutto stronzo
perché c'è darth vader anche batman come
scelgo i capitoli in questa roba da
ragazzi non lo voglio sapere al round 1
meno domande ci facciamo giusto gioco è
meglio e ad evitare il biglietto al
controllore tieni zio tutto tuo
si vabbè ma almeno mafai fermare il
treno proprio così lui prende le fermate
mentre il treno va a me fitz el sayed
dei sono curiosissimo di vederla sta
roba ragazzi ve lo dico devo salvare la
luna prima che esploda salve posso
sradicare la bandiera perfetto
sei contento zio ben e la madonna con
tara grossa st bomba per far fuori tutta
la crew non siamo in mezzo alla giungla
salve zio una lavatrice
ma guarda non avevo proprio dubbi che si
potesse trovare una lavatrice e mezzo
alla giungla una corda giusto era giusto
non ci posso credere mongolfiera ok se
riesco a fare giusto anche la
mongolfiera albo sono eccitato ricche
assenso
oddio oddio che è successo non volevo
fare così comunque ve lo dico va beh non
importa reflex ed ai cieli faremo nel
prossimo ragazza comunque il secondo
l'ho già fatto il che è incredibile un
phon devo usare il phon su un tizio
perfetto non vedo come questo possa
salvare infatti nella banca siamo in
banca ragazzi come la salva la banca c'è
un ladro che ha piazzato la bomba sul
cavo e c'è un tizio ci penso io zio
uso i codici perfetto o catturato la
persona sbagliata la prova bene era
giusto come maccarone possibile va bene
siamo al circo ragazzi e la bomba è
quella lì quindi che faccio salto dentro
per febbre avessimo complimenti me
quitte un salto da maestro 2 su 6
ragazzi non è male non è male ho visto
di peggio prendo il tizio tiro calci
avvenne perfetto non era così va bene
avevo intuito guardare al tizio il
bidone va bene cosa sta succedendo ma
stai facendo
va bene sta succedendo rega è ok va beh
va beh vuol buttare qualcos'altro non so
adesso non c'è perfetto ho buttato giù
tutto buttato giù un tizio mi sono
buttato giù io ho buttato sulla bomba
perfetto non ho capito
ok mi sono buttato brame non l'ho
passato il cerchio senza un motivo
vabbè non capisco io sto gioco e ha
quindi devo prenderla bomba è tipo darla
al tizio che volerà con la bomba è
infatti perfetto questo l'avevo capito
che poi è andato sulla terra ed è
esplosa la terra però la luna e salva
quindi va bene geniale geniale katz
memphis ultimo livello ragazzi se lo
azzecco sono tre su tre
cosa che non farò mai devo spegnere la
miccia con la mano ok bene del caso
successo perché perché perché
bonus round no ti prego non voglio fare
secoli già mi va in pappa il cervello
coi round normale ma cosa sta roba o
capi bellissimo dovevo salvare una mucca
che volava non ho capito a cosa servono
i volontari
la giornata è salva ma pixel torniamo
indietro vaghe meglio niente round due
ragazzi non so che dirvi è la cosa più
non sensi li abbia mai giocato e
continua ad esserlo però vabbè magari
fermati stava niente devo capire cosa
fare della mia vita ogni livello che
passò in fila gli o nel culo se è da
veramente prende prende il satellite
però e sposa lo stesso però ho fatto una
gran cosa la balena non ho visto neanche
quali erano i primi maledizione
pinocchio va bene c'è una scatola di
medicinali che la metto qua non ci
crederà era il pepe c'ho azzeccato
quindi fa chi è ha osservato la balena
raga non ci posso credere
perfetto posso chiederti che cosa mica
stai facciona lo voglio sapere va bene
così che cos'è questo un banjo banjo
banjo e fede ben due fedez devo tirarti
un banjo in faccia non è un mezzo
perfetto non ho capito cosa devo fare va
bene quanto senso in questo videogame
ragazzi veramente non ho parole che
esistono un clip e c'è un [ __ ] che
libera anche i sto gioco ci mancava
guarda solo qua il diamante e tocco
prima e altri per ovviamente quello che
esplode e io ovviamente lo accarezzo
come se fosse un animaletto da compagnia
bene perfetto ci ho provato ragazzi va
bene non importa al nuvoletta cioè di a
questo è dio
ciao dio mi dovresti spiegare come
buttare giù grazie dio c'è ma cosa è
successo
ho vinto niente da grazie all'aiuto di
dio abbiamo vinto ragazzi non ho capito
come nuova beffa invece a quella
paradiso questo l'inferno che fa questo
è satana
ciao satana ok era una pozione polisucco
ma come l'antenna devo staccare per
forza metto l'antenna nel deretano del
tizio sul tizio così il tizio si becca
il fulmine no niente non ho capito da ci
devo fare con sto qua minchia bene
mi metto a suonare be prefetto la danza
della pioggia dentro casa soprattutto la
danza della pioggia dentro casa mi
mancava la gara del creeper non lo
accarezzo vado sul diamante però sarà
sbagliatissimo andare sul diamante
perché mi che mi sembra troppo ovvio ci
sarà qualcos'altro che non vedo ha detto
chiamo il diamante te lo dò il crif era
l'unica roba che posso fare il clipper
si è mangiato il diamante e non posso
fare altro non c'è nient'altro zio cosa
devo fare
vabbè non ho capito non importa
veicolare tutto su satana per quale
obama che il cazzo gioco mi che non lo
capisco ogni volta che vado ogni volta
che finisco un livello sono sempre più
allibito non si capisce niente non c'è
verso ficcato l'antenna di sotto e non è
allora cosa devo fare ho fatte tutte a
devo prendere a calci tizio è l'unica
che rimane prendere a calci tizio poi
non lo so cosa devo fare
ho preso il diamante va bene il diamante
lo devo prendere cosa ci faccio e se
devo fare che sto cazzo di diamante lì
l'ho messo sul piede non capisce cosa
deve fare e felice stai calmo
stai calmo stai calmo stai calmo sporca
la [ __ ] cosa vuoi dalla vita mia
ragazzi non capisco vi giuro che non
capiscono non ha senso l'unica roba che
rimasta da fare questo tizio prenderlo a
calci poi non c'è allora non so cosa
devo fare
prendo a calci la mucca kg il culo alla
mucca sono entrato di casa con la bomba
perfetto ma chi è questa l'ho fatta
perfetto ok con un detto manca altri o
ragazzi clipper non lo bel vi giuro che
non lo capisco
santo gesù santo benedetto quale motivo
di sono messo a giocare a star ormai
siamo arrivati a questo facciamo lo
chiediamo sta roba perché mio dio poi
fermare il treno perché [ __ ] 6
dato poco da fare fattoria nella vecchia
fattoria ci sta zio tobia con una canna
in mano è una canna quella devo buttare
giù questo bene ho dato fuoco a zio
tobia perfetto non era esattamente
quello che richiedeva a livello però
avere sempre soddisfazione a dar fuoco a
zia tobia cos'è una prigione questa
perché ci sono io io sono in prigione
bellissimi vuoi fuggire zio dio cosa
faccia perché tu archi sulla scala per
quale ma cosa sta succedendo ma quanto
può essere stupito da 1m pixel
cos'è sta roba beh per feb eni il
perfettissimo quarto livello è un faro
bello ed è il simbolo di batman
e c'è anche batman re ovviamente c'è una
bomba c'è batman e io che cosa ci sto a
fare qua se c'è lui dovresti salvare tu
la giornata buona nulla te lo devo
urlare in faccia a salva la giornata a
[ __ ] anno quella da segnalatori di
batman per far bene la mia incredibile
intelligenza nel risolvere le situazioni
hayez e comunque ogni livello è sempre
fottutamente cosa è successo mi sono
messo a giocare a tetris con un computer
benissimo quali ho sbagliati
praticamente tutti tranne questo è stato
bellissimo
mica che scenario da un anno possiamo
posso farti una domanda mi interessi
questa gallina mentre io vado a
risolvere la situazione grazie non è
spuntato un sottomarino da dal nulla
perfetto fattoria ragazzi fattoria
fattori e non ho capito la mucca ho
preso una luce come preso una mucca la
metto sud un bob la lancio su 28
raggiunto doveva lanciare la mucca
sull'elefante benissimo non avevo dubbi
prigione dalla prigione non l'ho capita
sinceramente devo strappare il manifesto
fa ho messo le dei baffi al manifesto
così nessuno mi riconosce perfetto però
è saltato tutto in aria lo stesso quindi
non è servita un pene però cosa vuoi che
faccia non finita il bastone di nonno
che non si regge più in piedi poverino
glielo messo nel culo st ok non trovo a
parlare gamma di che cazzo stiamo a
parlare usciamo usciamo da glielo in
testa ma edizione dialogue bravo non è
neanche caduto ha preso la forma suo
agio il geniale
due su due ragazze faccio giusto questa
ti prego fai qualcosa di decente questa
bottiglia d'ayala capitano a offrirgli
del buon room da bere dai e arancio
avevano uncino poverino va bene ti prego
iddio fa qualcosa prima che ti ammazzi
critical mass culo critico niente non è
servito avete ho provato sparo senza la
birra è uscita siamo affondati però non
va bene perché non siamo esplosi
preferito la nave affonda pian piano ma
va bene o spegnere la sirena o scarsa
perfetto o scassato tutto era giusto non
ever dai ragazzi ma doni non ci sarei
mai arrivato che lo giuro fatto a
carissimo tre minuti e ventidue per
questa merda lega e anche il capitolo
tre ragazzi miei è andato non ci posso
credere ma anche al quarto che sarà
veramente una roba geniale fatemi vedere
solo come come si approccia a ho buttato
proprio il vecchio giu benissimo
d'accordo ragazzi che un gruppo che
l'episodio spero che vi sia piaciuto
farò il quarto l'ultimo capitolo nel
prossimo cosa sente ragazzi se video
presentarsi ad un commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook perché di
dotare descrizione ci vediamo proseguito